it is immoral to expect the very people
who are victimized and attacked by these
people
to pay for these people to have room and
board for the rest of their [__] life
yeah I would say
no
okay
because
this is an interesting one it is anyway
Francis I'm not going to interrupt or
interfere in any way right but tell us
why you do not support the death penalty
uh unlike 63 of our listeners and
viewers why do I not support the deaf
even in those circumstances where we eat
no for a fact that the person is who
they are and they're guilty for of the
crime that they've been convicted of
even you know for a fact because the
court system is valuable people are
fallible there is there will always be
an instance where someone will be
executed
and there will be a mistake there will
be a miscarriage of Justice why what if
what if you only do it in cases where
there's video evidence for example you
you can literally see the person
stabbing people okay what happens when
we when AI becomes better not AI when
technology becomes better and we get
deep fakes and things like that what
happens then
well I think you deal with it at that
point but we don't have that technology
now but by the time we implement the
death penalty which will take years and
years of legislation and back and forth
I'd do it in a day
which is [__] rubber stamping and
it's through
I see that you're bringing stuff up
that's not relevant like no no that is
relevant because that is going to become
that is that is good that is going to be
that is going to become mainstream
technology in a couple of years so
you're saying that
you're saying the mainstream media and
the government are going to fake
somebody stabbing people on the on
London Bridge no but then that person is
going to get executed no that's not what
I'm saying I'm saying uh for a video
footage could erroneously be used as
evidence in a court which then later
could turn out to be fake no but I'm
talking about a situation let's take a
specific case because that's what I'm
trying to get at right you've got a
terrorist who's stabbing people on
London Bridge there's footage from 53
different angles showing it there's
witness evidence from about 100 people
yeah right and the guy himself says I
wanted to kill those evil uh whatever
Infidel dog pigs dog pig dogs whatever
dogs yeah no one right
yeah anyway why are you against the
death penalty in that situation uh
because you turn that person into a
martyr
and then they become a martyr to the
court and you know and then for sure
anyone who considers them a martyr to
the cause would consider them a martyr
to the cause even if they didn't get
executed no but
what would happen is then that person
would become a symbol of the evil West
blah blah blah blah blah and there would
be
I think that would actually make
terrorism worse if you executed that
person
even make terrorism worse yes it would
how because it would radicalize more
people it would be that is what they do
yeah because they have the death penalty
yes so how would us having the death
penalty radicalize them to attack us
more right why would it because number
one you're applying logic to them and
their their beliefs are not particularly
logical number one and number two you're
turning that person into a martyr they
become a symbol if you think about lots
of people throughout history who have
become venerated it's because they have
a cause and then we're executed whilst
they were in pursuit of that course
so but throwing them into prison for
life that doesn't do that no not as much
we don't no certainly not as much think
about uh people who like you know rich
right is he is he his symbol no he's not
he's because he didn't blow anything up
no but what about the people who killed
Lee Rigby or the or the London Bridge
bombers you don't even remember any
other names I know but you would do if
we actually yes yeah no you wouldn't you
just treat them the same and by the way
uh you'd you'd uh you'd have some kind
of thing where you're not the media are
not allowed to bang on endlessly about
their name well the media wouldn't be
but as you know in the days in the era
of social media that isn't an option
okay fine uh I mean I I think that's
[__] personally and I think you're
covering up or something else but I'm
serious I don't mean that as an insult I
mean like I think you have a natural
opposition to the death penalty which is
more about like the sanctity of life or
thou shall not kill or whatever and
you're covering it up with this excuse
and here's and here is how we're going
to reveal that okay so what about
someone who is caught on video nonsing
hundreds of children
somebody who's caught on videos
we know for a fact they did it there's
no confusion there's no ambiguity we we
know that they they are a full-blown
knot yeah full-blown series who's ruined
the lives of hundreds of children and
their families yes right are you going
to make them a martyr for nonsense right
it's a different thing right so what's
that what's their explanation why you
can't kill them why you can't kill them
yeah
for that crime so this is a man so he's
obviously a man no could be a trans
woman yeah that is true that is true
slap on the wrist okay so this is a a
trans woman or a man who is a pedophile
and has
and has announced hundreds of kids
should he be killed by the state before
his crimes
now he gets it right
I would say
no
okay because
this is an interesting one it is
this I I don't I don't I don't know the
answer to this one if I'm being honest
why shouldn't we kill him
because ultimately
I don't think the state should be in
charge of
someone being executed for a crimes
committed in that country why is that
because like I said there is always a
chance that no no but forget about that
let's say we have technology that allows
you to determine with 100 but I think
that is a false that's a false position
because you are never going to be a
hundred percent certain in a conviction
well or with terrorism for example you
are right but the problem is as well if
you have a broader belief right so this
is why sorry to interrupt I wanna I
wanna hear what you have to say but this
is why I gave you the non-example second
because I think the Martyr thing is your
way of covering the fact that you just
don't think the state should execute
people right you don't and that's fair
enough yeah that's a perfectly
legitimate point of view yeah but you're
saying then your son to come up with
arguments that in my opinion is also not
what you actually believe you just don't
think the state should execute people I
don't understand
however I would say that my terrorism
point is a fair and legitimate one fine
forget about that so let's say
hypothetically yeah we had technology
that allowed you to know a hundred
percent which we've done what do you
mean we don't we don't what what if you
have video footage and hundreds of
witnesses yeah all these people go this
guy's a nonsense yeah okay and I have
video footage of him announcing children
okay that he recorded himself okay and
then when he gets to call he goes yeah I
love nonsing I'm I am the best knots in
the history of nonsense
right your honor your honor yeah he's
polite let's say that happens yeah why
is it wrong for the state to execute
that person why is it wrong for the
state to execute that person
because ultimately I I I don't think the
state should have that power over its
citizens fine that's just a statement of
opinion but why do you think that
because even if that person is guilty
further down the line there could be
further miscarriages of Justice
because wherever you have a court system
wherever you have human beings you have
the potential and the propensity for
flawed decision making
okay but
I mean in my opinion you're slightly
dodging the question here
and I think it comes look I'm projecting
I could be wrong but I think you just
fundamentally think that it's it's not
about the the potential for error you
just don't think the state should
execute people because you're a nice
liberal right thinking person nice
liberal right thinking personally I
think that's it if I'm honest but I may
be projecting and maybe that's not fair
um I know a large part of it is actually
the
a large part look for instance actually
when it comes to most left-leaning
people I think the left is too soft on
crime right I think I think the fact
that there's a lot of people I think the
fact that Larry Gary Glitter got eight
years in prison for his crimes as a
[__] disgrace he should have got a
life sentence he should have been banged
up and the key thrown away he's a
disgusting individual and the only time
he should have been allowed out is when
he's absolutely riddled with our awful
illness and he's got a week to live
personally right that's where I stand on
the on a lot of the types of these types
of issues I think a lot of crime in this
country is caused by repeat offenders
who bring misery among sapporis and most
vulnerable people in society and this
liberal way of looking at quote
no it's bollocks all right okay number
one and number two we should also invest
more in the prison system so the people
who are who can be rehabilitated have a
good chance of being rehabilitated to
learn skills I agree unfortunately there
is a small cool group of criminals who
will never be rehabilitated and we need
to be honest about that now you're
getting it right I still I've always get
it no no that's not what I'm saying not
saying if there's a core group of
criminals you keep reoffending who
commit heinous crimes and you know who
they are and there's very clear evidence
yeah
with those group of people I don't think
we should kill them no
I don't I know you don't yeah but my
point is you keep coming up with
different excuses for different things
which is how I know there's something
deeper that sits underneath all of those
beliefs yeah
right
is it possibly just a good Catholic man
it's impossible Thou shalt not kill
maybe it is because that's not the
Commandment you know
that's not the Commandment now what is
the Commandment the Commandment actually
means that shall not murder yeah talk to
Sophie the bleeder about it really right
so it's not about people being killed
because we accept the military kills
yeah except the state I mean if you
think about the times in which those
Commandments were Commandments were
introduced yeah there's quite a lot of
killing going on yeah there was right so
the Commandment is that shall not murder
yeah as in that shall not kill other
people against the laws of the society
that you operate yeah right so we every
society in history is accepted that the
state has the right to kill people in
some way yeah right and also I mean you
get into a lot of trouble with your
pro-choice position in that situation
how do you mean if you believe that
abortion should be possible and legal
that's hard to reconcile with thou shall
not kill yeah
right yeah I mean but then you come up
then that goes into the argument of when
does somebody become a a yeah
I think we know yeah even pro-abortion
people like uh Anne Faraday who we had
on the show except that the fetus is
life yeah right so if you're this is
this is why I'm kind of teasing this out
with you because if you believe that
abortion should be allowed yeah that
means you accepted killing in certain
circumstances is
possible and should be allowed right and
so how do we live in a society where
you're allowed to kill unborn children
but you're not allowed to kill people
who commit heinous crimes the children
are completely innocent yeah right so if
you're talking about the risk of taking
innocent life I think the risk is much
higher with something like abortion
isn't it yes and yet we allow it to
happen and we don't we don't execute
criminals yeah does that make sense
does that make sense
I see we're going to make you Pro death
penalty
because I
I think that I don't have a lot of faith
in the court system I don't really have
actually a lot of faith in human beings
as a result when it comes to making
decisions I think the propensity for
area is too great there have been so
many times that people have been given a
life sentence and then found that it's
been completely wrong but it's already a
different standard of evidence to the
one that I'm suggesting
I'm not saying that if some if the Court
decides that Beyond Reasonable Doubt you
did something you get executed the next
day I'm saying if there are situations
with modern technology that allow us to
know for a fact whether somebody
committed a crime there are hundreds of
people in this country who've committed
crimes that we know for a fact they
committed there's no doubt there's not
there's not any question about it but
there will always be miscarriages of
Justice content and which is why the
standard has to be completely different
for the death penalty if there's any
doubt whatsoever then that's different
right but then what about the cases
where there was no doubt at the time and
then suddenly new evidence was brought
so that's not what happens 10 20 years
it is what happened it's not what
happens on the current legal standard
you're convicted of things if you it's
been proven Beyond a reasonable doubt
that's not what I'm saying I'm saying if
it's proven Beyond any doubt I.E you've
got video evidence from many different
cameras DNA evidence if it's appropriate
witness evidence and the person
themselves says yeah I [__] loved it
right in that situation
I don't see why you shouldn't do it and
anyway my point is broadly how do you
reconcile that with being pro-choice
how do I reconcile that I've been
pro-choice how do you know I'm
pro-choice
I don't are you pro-choice genuinely I
don't know
I don't know
you know what you're doing right now
that's you you've been training with
your boxing coach ducking and weaving
I'd like with with the abortion thing
that actually the more we went into it
the more uncomfortable I became around
the whole thing the more I found out
about it the more deeply uncomfortable I
became
so your anti-abortion boss anti-death
penalty I mean that's more of a
consistent point of view
but are you anti-abortion though
the answer is I want to control women's
bodies the answer is is genuinely is I
don't know I don't know because on the
surface of it you go you know want your
body your choice you go absolutely yeah
and then when you start factoring in the
fact that it's an innocent child being
and what I would feel is if that was my
child
I'd be absolutely devastated yeah and be
completely devastated unless you wanted
to have a peaceful life exactly and
money
you know and the chance to enjoyment
Alice coin in the chat says no uterus no
choice and the story
um all right well so what do you think
so let's explore what do you think what
I think I think it's deeply immoral for
uh people like us uh to be paying
hundreds of thousands of pounds to keep
terrorists alive who want to destroy
everything that we stand for and who've
gone out of their way to murder people
in this country I think on that argument
alone I mean I'm approaching it from a
Jewish position obviously right the
financial side of it I think it's
immoral why should we say tomorrow why
is it a moral why should we pay each of
us thousands of pounds to keep people
alive who want to not only want to
murder us but have murdered us with the
specific intent of intimidating this
country and the people of this country
and undermining and destroying Western
Civilization why should we keep them
alive you have a right to life right
like all people but the moment you start
going out and deliberately killing
innocent people for your warped
political ideology you give that up
and from a purely practical point of
view I don't want to be paying for you
to [__] stay alive why is it our job
and these people do you know how much it
costs to keep people in prison yeah it
costs a lot of money I was around 30 000
pounds a year I think it's way more than
that is it I think it's more like 50 or
60. could you look it up I thought it
was around 30 years ago I think it's
more than that right so
from that perspective I don't buy the
Martyr argument by the way because the
martyrdom the the tariffs they aren't
celebrating people for being killed
they're celebrating for people for doing
things right yeah so uh if you go and
stab loads of people or if you fly a
plane into the into the World Trade
Center that's why they will remember
your name it's not because you got
punished by the state for it
um and so 58 Grand apparently some
people are saying in the chat that's
what I thought it was uh 48 Grand 14 so
50 Grand so think about that so
basically that's about 100 grams worth
of income if you pay about half of it in
time so maybe it's a bit more maybe it's
like 120 right yeah not not more sorry
less maybe it's about 80 grand right so
you have someone has to earn 80 grand in
this country to keep one of these
[__] in prison for a year right
and polar red says KK according to U.S
figures more expensive to execute it's
not more expensive to execute it's more
expensive because the whole death row
process takes about 20 years and you
have to keep these people in prison for
20 years with this system if there's if
there's no doubt about their guilt sure
they can have an appeal process but one
time and if that fails off you got my
son off you go if you go off you go and
so from my perspective it is immoral to
expect the very people who are
victimized and attacked by these people
to pay for these people to have room and
board for the rest of their [__] life
yeah look the the problem is as well
it's like it's not going to be the
implementation of this system
is going to take years and years that's
right that's what Nick collect said
about nuclear power stations and look
where we are yeah exactly right my point
is look the practicalities of it are
obviously important but I'm just talking
on a theoretical basis right right
I don't see any reason to oppose the
death penalty for people whose crime is
beyond doubt any doubt we have evidence
from a bunch of sources it's very clear
for heinous crimes and particularly for
people whose entire purpose was to
intimidate uh and Destroy Western
Civilization I don't see why these
people uh should be allowed to live
there we go by the way I wasn't actually
being facetious about the abortion thing
I genuinely don't know yeah I mean I'm
in a similar position
and actually the thing is of abortion is
the more I
more I'm actually starting to not enjoy
my thoughts on it
what does that mean you're massively Pro
abortion